all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa I have two all
form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allforum.com Pacman
I want to start today going back to the
Pandora papers now the Pandora papers
are different than the Panama papers the
Pandora papers as we talked about what
was it now I guess it must have been
about
um about a five weeks ago or something
like that the beginning of October the
Pandora papers are these leaks about 12
million different documents and they uh
it's it was an undertaking involving
more than 600 journalists in more than
115 countries it was all organized or
data obtained by the icij that's the
international Consortium of
investigative journalists in Washington
DC they worked with all these different
media organizations it was a massive I
mean it's an incredible accomplishment
journalistically to even do such a big
project it's a huge project and also it
was huge in that it exposed hidden
wealth it exposed money laundering it
exposed attack tax avoidance and much of
it by the world's Rich the world's
powerful many of the elites as they are
often known
we now have a specific story about
consequences thanks to the Pandora
papers now consequences but it's sort of
like when Trump was impeached by the
house it was a consequence but we knew
there would be no conviction sort of
similar and this comes to us from the
country of Chile the guardian reporting
that the Chilean president has been
impeached over the revelations in the
Pandora papers now it's impeached
impeached by the lower house not
expected to be convicted similar to
Donald Trump's impeachment I'll tell you
that up front but we're going to get to
that in a moment a Chile's president
Sebastian Pineda has been impeached by
the lower house of Congress setting up a
trial in the nation's Senate over
allegations that he favored the sale of
a family property while in office the
vote to impeach past but barely it had
78 votes in 155-member chamber of
deputies there was the one of the
craziest things is there was like a real
not a filibuster but there was one of
these Marathon sessions 20 hours 67
legislators voted against including
several members of the opposition some
abstained or were absent and 78 voted in
favor
um Pineda is unlikely to be removed by
the 43-member upper house where the
opposition has only 24 of the 29 votes
so
um he he has the overwhelming majority
of the votes in the Upper House the
trial will come in the heat of a general
election campaign first round of
Elections set for the 21st of November
the term ends on the 11th of March Chile
does not permit presidential re-election
to consecutive terms so term limited out
anyway so what's that issue here
this was not like the most explosive of
the revelations to be totally clear but
the leaked documents revealed a
controversial deal to sell the Pineda
family stake in the dominga mining
project and a contract found by the
project suggested the first 138 million
of the sale
was made through shell companies
registered in the bvis the British
Virgin Islands the documents suggests
the final payment on the mine sale in
2011 hinged on the government declining
to declare its location in north central
Chile a nature preserve so it's sort of
like cronyism favors it's it's
everything you know
um Pineda said he had not been involved
in managing the companies and didn't
even realize the connection the
government at that time was headed by
Pineda didn't do so despite appeals from
environmentalists the president's office
noted last month that pineda's first
term as president from 2010 to 2014
hadn't started when the sale was agreed
to
and that prosecutors and courts decided
in 2017 no crime was committed and the
president wasn't involved and all taxes
were paid and that his Holdings are now
in a blind trust etc etc uh however they
did ultimately get the majority needed
in the lower house for this impeachment
so what what do we take from this what
do we make of it on the one hand we can
say and I think it's accurate to say
um activism and investigative journalism
have real impacts in the real world it's
a it's it's one of the first examples of
the Pandora papers actually being that
they are not just these sort of like
um what would what would we call it it's
not disaster porn it's not Elite porn
it's sort of like these are not merely
wow look at this look at the money and
look at the things that they do it it
led to a real consequence of sorts
that being said
um you could argue this is kind of a
token move that there is no way in hell
that he's actually going to be removed
because the impeachment trial in the
upper house is going to say no we are
not removing him he can't run in the
next election anyway and is down to the
last four and a half or so months there
um so that's a fair position as well
this is kind of a token move for me the
takeaway is this was an extraordinarily
well carried out project of
investigative journalism it exposes that
even many of the supposed Good Guys in
power are still doing all of the same
things that the so-called bad guys are
doing when it comes to cronyism and
money and Deals and the like and it
furthers for me the importance of these
kinds of projects continuing to be
supported and continuing to do their
work
um we you know we you look at history
and whether it's Woodward and Bernstein
with Nixon or whatever example you want
to pick
um investigative journalism
exposes important things and it's one of
the first things that goes when media
organizations say we've got to tighten
the belt and as I've explained to you
before if you are a media organization
and you are given the option of okay
we're going to do investigative
journalism which means funding reporters
who have to do in many cases significant
travel uh paying sometimes for different
aspects of conducting the investigative
journalism
for a story that they might work on for
a year or more and we might get
something out of it but we might get not
get something out of it that's one
option as a media entity you can pay for
that or on the complete other side of
the spectrum you say I'm going to hire
writers who will sit at home and just
rewrite articles from other news
organizations adding our spin
not naming anybody but that's a business
model you have a website you don't do
original reporting you say oh look
here's a story reported by The
Washington Post in the New York Times
let me put a different headline on it
quote from it and publish it and run ads
on that that is dirt cheap to do
compared to this type of investigative
journalism which can take months or
years and
um we don't really get much out of the
ladder but we get a lot out of the
former but the former costs a lot more
so this is also related to the reality
of of sort of the industry of Journalism
at this point in time uh interesting I
don't think this will lead to much in
terms of the Chilean president but it is
at least a consequence a consequence
from the Pandora papers you know over
the last couple of years a few years
it's become this default refrain from
the right that social media is left-wing
and it amplifies left-wing messages and
ideas it suppresses right-wing messages
and ideas sometimes by de-prioritizing
the content sometimes by straight up
Banning the purveyors of the content
Etc most of us understand this but very
often it's easy to kind of get lost in
the messaging when the real way to look
at these claims is to look at them
empirically now Facebook is one that has
been very much Under Fire by the right
the ban of trump became a Flashpoint in
this case to be made that many of them
are making that all these platforms
including Facebook just want to prop up
left-wing messages and ideology but
intuitively it didn't really ever seem
that that was the case with Facebook we
I've mentioned to you anecdotally Ben
Shapiro does so well one of the top
Facebook
Publishers and Dan bongino we've talked
about and all these right-wingers it
seems that between that and Mark
Zuckerberg kind of at minimum looking
the other way when it comes to the way
that the right used Facebook to spread
disinformation about the election and
vaccines Etc
certainly doesn't seem that Facebook is
propping up the left Media Matters
undertook a very interesting
investigation and Quantified a lot of
this and it found that the top political
posts on Facebook are almost always and
almost exclusively right wing I've
mentioned this before every day Media
Matters uses Facebook's crowdtangle tool
to identify and share the top the 10
posts with the most interactions from
top political and news related Facebook
pages our list also specifies the
ideological leaning
um Media Matters and others have
demonstrated again and again there is no
bias or censorship against conservatives
on Facebook despite claims to the
contrary the data set is more evidence
that no such bias exists here is a
sample day but a typical day on Facebook
this was two days ago so Monday you look
at the top 10 Facebook posts about news
and politics it was Breitbart Don Jr Ben
Shapiro Franklin Graham another
Breitbart the Hodge twins Fox News and
Ben Shapiro eight out of the ten are
hard right hard right posts one of the
top 10 posts is the link from NPR and
we'll look at it in a second which is
considered non-aligned ideology the
right says NPR leans left NPR is
sticks to facts overwhelmingly in their
news reporting and then one is a Hillary
Clinton post but wait until I show you
what the Hillary Clinton post actually
is so a eighty percent of the top
Facebook news and politics post Monday
conservative
now we go and we actually look at what
the posts are
the Breitbart post is about standing by
Aaron Rodgers despite his lies about
being vaccinated okay that's like a hard
propaganda post the second one is a Don
Jr post with a picture of Don senior
Donald Trump that says miss him yet not
very substantive the Ben Shapiro post is
one about it's called boom man shot by
Rittenhouse admits he pointed at a gun
at Rittenhouse the Hillary Clinton post
is just a New York City marathon picture
of uh I I believe that that's Chelsea
Clinton it's it's not even political
it's from Hillary but it's just someone
who ran the marathon so it's not even
political in the sense that these other
posts are political
um there's a Franklin Graham post about
his uh heart surgery that he got
and then the NPR post is about
conservatives being mad about Big Bird
getting vaccinated so even the NPR post
that made it is one that appeals to
conservatives because it's about the
uprising from the right about Big Bird
announcing that he got a covet vaccine
so even when we look at these 10 top 10
posts on Facebook from November 8th
um the one that's left leaning is just a
picture of someone who ran the marathon
it's not even a left-wing message and
the one from NPR which is considered
non-aligned politically is one that
would be particularly appealing to
conservatives so what's the takeaway
here the takeaway is when you broadly
hear this platform favors the left or
that platform favors the left
um you might say that sounds reasonable
or you might say it doesn't sound
reasonable but we are able to quantify
these things we are able to quantify it
and at least as far as Facebook goes
routinely
this is not an outlier day routinely the
top performers are almost exclusively
right-wing Publishers let me know your
thoughts you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman we're going to take a quick
break we'll we'll talk about the Aaron
Rodgers apology we're going to talk
about the judge's decision in the Trump
Riot documents we're going to talk about
the Paul goes our video where he's
depicted as killing AOC in anime form
all of it is upcoming find me on Twitter
at dpacman
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home I got my first
all-form sofa a year ago I just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas I would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't be the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 off when you go to allforum.com
Pacman the link is is right underneath
this video
remember that our program depends on the
support of viewers and listeners like
you we have a membership program you can
sign up and within it's really 45
seconds with average computer skills you
can sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
an extra show every day produced just
for our members you'll get a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
and lots of other great perks join
pacman.com is the place to sign up
things have exploded over the anime
video tweeted out by Republican
Congressman Paul gozar in which a
cartoon version of him sort of anime his
face on it a cartoon an anime version of
Paul goes are is depicted as killing
democratic congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez the demands now range from
investigate through a house ethics panel
to arrest
Paul goes are to send the FBI to Paul
gozar to talk to him about this there's
also a sort of hypocrisy component to
this which I'm going to talk about but
it is a wild wild story so let's start
with Newsweek reporting Paul goes our
faces growing calls to be arrested
over video showing him killing AOC
killing AOC
Congressman Paul gozar is facing calls
to be arrested or expelled from Congress
after the lawmaker shared an anime video
depicting him killing congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez in most jobs in
most jobs if it's determined that during
your off time whatever that means you
were tweeting videos
depicting you killing a co-worker you
would be fired you would be fired you
would be fired okay it's just not even
it's not even there's not even a debate
about it
um Congressman goes our sparked Fierce
backlash on Sunday after he tweeted an
anime video showing him killing
congresswoman ocasio-cortez the video
based on the anime Attack on Titan shows
gozar killing the New York lawmaker with
a sword before launching himself at
President Joe Biden within hours the
Tweet went viral as of Tuesday morning
had been viewed more than 3.2 million
times the video and depiction of
violence against AOC LED numerous
figures to call for Congressman gozar to
be arrested or expelled from Congress
Democrats critics call for action
against Congressman Paul gozar over his
grotesque post this is from Huffington
Post in any workplace in America if a
co-worker made an anime video killing
another co-worker that person would be
fired my sentiments exactly more than
half a dozen house Dems one house
Republican and scores of critics have
condemned and called for action against
Paul goes our Monday after he posted a
doctored anime video that depicts him
killing congresswoman AOC
goes our tweeted an edited version of
the opening credits of the Japanese
anime series Attack on Titan showing
himself as the main character who then
slashes the neck of a foe with
ocasio-cortez's face
um AOC tweeted about it so while I was
on route to Glasgow a creepy member I
work with who fundraises for Neo-Nazi
groups that's true shared a fantasy
video of him killing me and he'll face
no consequences because GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy cheers him on with excuses fun
Monday well back to work
and then just another aspect to this
which Media Matters covered goes our
tweet reveals a double standard in cable
news's coverage of extremism and
civility in 2019 cable news devoted more
attention to a democratic congresswoman
cursing than it's now giving to a
republican Congressman tweeting an anime
video of killing a colleague
um
this is a reference to well there's a
couple of different things so first of
all remember the incident where Steve
Steve King rather embraced white
supremacy and then there was when
Rashida Talib said impeached the MFR so
you go back and you look at CNN Fox News
and MSNBC they all devoted
overwhelmingly more time to Rashida
Talib cursing versus Steve King
embracing white supremacy and we're
seeing the point from um uh Media
Matters here is that we're seeing the
exact same Dynamic play out uh with this
situation now one other funny thing
about Paul goes are and it's not even
really that funny
uh he has a whole bunch of siblings like
it's one of these families where there's
just kids upon kids upon kids there's a
very interesting
um video where back in 2018 his siblings
endorsed his opponent and the ad is very
cleverly done where you don't know until
later that these are all his siblings at
first it just kind of sounds like it's
random people saying I don't like Paul
gozar check this out this is this is a
good one Paul closer the congressman
isn't doing anything to help Rural
America Paul's absolutely not working
for his district if they care about
health care they care about their
children's health care
they would hold him to account if they
care about jobs
they would hold him to account
if he actually cared about people in
rural Arizona
I bet he'd be fighting for social
security for better access to health
care I better he I bet he would be
researching what is the most insightful
water policy to help the environment of
Arizona sustain itself and be successful
and he's not listening to you and he
doesn't have your interests at heart my
name is Tim gosar David gosar Grace
gosar Joan gosar Gaston Go sir Jennifer
gosar Paul gosar is my brother my
brother and I endorse Dr Brill Dr Brill
endorse Dr David Brill for congress
um gozar really is one of the most
disgusting members of Congress will
there be consequences for tweeting a
video a glamorizing drama dramatizing
him killing a colleague
unfortunately there probably will not
there probably will not alright so let's
follow up about the Aaron Rodgers story
Aaron Rodgers is apologizing to anyone
that felt misled okay Aaron Rodgers is
sorry
if he upset anybody
yeah so let's reset
um NFL quarterback Aaron Rodgers has
issued a pseudo bogus apology after
getting hot lying about being quote
immunized against covet 19. catching
covid and then saying on the Pat McAfee
show that he's been listening to Joe
Rogan for medical advice and is taking
Ivermectin so it's like where do we even
start I I guess let's kind of lead up to
this first here is a reminder this is
Aaron Rodgers the Green Bay Packers
quarterback in the summer this was in
August asked have you been vaccinated
and he says I've been immunized which is
a different word and it was a lie it was
a lie any conversation are you
vaccinated and what's your stance on
vaccinations yeah I've been immunized
um
you know there's a lot of uh
a lot of conversation around it around
the league and a lot of guys who so the
fact that this was a very strange word
salad might have been a sign he was
lying I've made statements and I made
statements the owners who made
statements
um you know those guys on the team that
haven't been vaccinated I think it's a
personal decision I'm not going to judge
those guys
um those guys have been vaccinated
they've contracted covid
um
so
it's it's an interesting issue that I
think we're going to see he's he's
interested in the issue he's also lying
lying lying so fine he lied about being
immunized vaccinated whatever he catches
covet great so then uh he's gonna miss
his last week's game or a few days ago
game
um admits that he was taking and is
taking medical advice from Joe Rogan
who's a podcaster Joe Rogan is not a
doctor
um and when he says this we played this
clip on Monday Pat McAfee can barely
contain his laughter he actually has to
cover his mouth to avoid laughing
directly in Aaron Rodgers face let's go
to that clip we looked at this on Monday
I consulted with a now good friend of
mine Joe Rogan
after he got covered and I've been doing
a lot of the stuff that he recommended
in his podcast right and you know on the
phone to me and I'm gonna have the best
immunity possible now okay so he made a
lot of dubious claims in that interview
where he said an Israeli study says you
get better immunity from just recovering
from covid of course what the Israeli
study says is that it's better not to
catch it at all
um but that you get actually the best
immunity from recovery plus vaccination
that's the best immunity so literally
what he says is a lie there as well so
then comes the apology and again it's
one of these pseudo apologies um New
York Magazine's Benjamin Hart had a
great phrase he calls it the
quintessential non-apology apology to
anyone that was upset this is a classic
we've seen this time and time again
um if anybody was upset because he lied
to them and put people at risk he's
apologizing if you found yourself upset
by that uh Okay let's listen so I just
want to start off this show by
acknowledging that you know I made some
comments that that people might have uh
felt were misleading and uh if you felt
his obvious lies were misleading uh his
completely demonstrable lies were
misleading he's sorry that you felt that
way
you know to anybody who felt misled by
those comments I'd take full
responsibility for those comments and
I'm excited about feeling better I'm
excited about moving forward and
hopefully getting back with my team
right and getting back to doing what I
do best and that's playing ball it's
been tough to be away from it
um I've been you know obviously dealing
with uh
the covet and I feel like I'm uh I'm on
on the other side of it thankfully and
thankful uh to still be able to uh have
some look forward to this weekend
hopefully well I appreciate you opening
with that and stating that and you
talked about the reflection that you've
had here all by yourself in your coveted
cave over there in Green Bay right
so it's a very crappy apology but like
why is he even doing it but this is
starting to cost him money now we can't
say for sure that's why he's issuing
this you know maybe
he could have offered a better apology
but he was dropped by a health care
company that he had been working with
for years
um Aaron Rodgers and Previa Health have
ended their nine-year partnership and
Previa put out a statement saying Previa
Health remains deeply committed to
protecting its patients staff providers
and communities amidst the pandemic this
includes encouraging and helping all
eligible populations to become
vaccinated to prevent the virus from
further significantly impacting lives
and livelihoods so Previa Health making
it clear
we're not going to do any we're not
we're not working with Aaron Rodgers
anymore
State Farm Cut most of its commercials
with Aaron Rodgers from being broadcast
this past weekend now it seems that
they're still continuing the partnership
for now and they put out a statement
saying quote we don't support some of
the statements he has made but we
respect his right to have his personal
view we recognize our customers
employees agents and brand ambassadors
come with all walks from all walks of
life with differing viewpoints on many
issues we encourage vaccinations but
respect everyone's choice to make uh
make decisions based on their personal
circumstances so that's the latest it
seems as though I mean listen at least
the timing is
uh companies that pay Aaron Rodgers have
partially or fully stepped back or
walked away from those relationships
and he issued this kind of bogus pseudo
apology so what's the takeaway here I
think the takeaway is uh get medical
advice from doctors don't lie about
being immunized or vaccinated or
whatever word you choose to use
um and don't spread disinformation I
mean the takeaways aren't really any
different just because it's Aaron
Rodgers rather than your crazy uncle
posting to Facebook it's really the
exact same takeaways and we're gonna
have more on this on our Instagram you
can follow the David Pacman show on
Instagram at davidpackman show you can
also follow me on Instagram at
david.pakman we're going to take a very
quick break and be back with much more
right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right we have two positive Donald
Trump stories today they are good
stories they are things that are good
for the left they are things that are
good for the country they are things
that are good for the world and for
everything that is good the first one is
uh Monday you might remember I told you
that Donald Trump filed before a judge
named Tanya chutkin had even made a
decision about Donald Trump's first
request to block documents and records
related to his activities leading up to
the Trump riots from being sent to the
committee investigating the Trump riots
before the judge even ruled on the first
one
Donald Trump already submitted a second
request saying no no you gotta here's
another reason why you should block this
stuff
and I told you on Monday we are waiting
for a decision from Judge Tanya chutkin
we now have gotten a decision I guess we
would call it the first decision and the
decision is the correct one it's a good
one and it is that uh judge chutkin has
denied Donald Trump's attempt to
withhold records from the January 6th
committee uh to put it very simply as
CNN explains a federal judge will allow
the U.S house to access hundreds of
pages of documents from Donald Trump's
presidency leading up to and about the
January 6th attack at the U.S Capitol in
a forceful rejection of Trump's recent
attempts to control information from his
White House the ruling Tuesday night
from Judge Tanya chutkin of the U.S
District Court in D.C is a blow to
Trump's efforts to keep more than 700
pages of records from the White House
secret though his legal team has
informed the court it tends to appeal
presidents are not Kings and plaintiff
is not president
um a very interesting final page from
the decision which you can easily find
online uh judge chutkin writes
accordingly the court holds that the
public interest lies in permitting the
combined will of the legislative and
executive branches to study the events
that led to and occurred on January 6
and to consider legislation to prevent
such events from occurring again judge
chutkin's conclusion is for the reasons
explained above the court will deny
plaintiff's request to enjoin defendants
from enforcing or complying with the
select committee's August 25 2021
requests because plaintiff is unlikely
to succeed on the merits of his claims
or suffer irreparable harm and because a
balance of the equities and public
interest bear against granting his
requested relief
so the um let's go back to the CNN
article
as of now the National Archives remains
on track to turn over to the house a
number of documents Friday now as I've
told you before this includes White
House call logs and video logs who was
Trump speaking to in those days leading
up to the riots and schedules related to
January 6th who was Trump meeting with
at the White House as well as three
pages of handwritten notes from Trump's
then Chief of Staff the outcome in court
also could help the house in its pursuit
of more information from those around
Trump including Witnesses who haven't
been subpoenaed and haven't spoken to
the committee yet what that means is
knowing who Trump spoke to knowing who
Trump met with will give the house
investigators
more information about hey here are
people Trump spoke to let's go and talk
to them let's subpoena them let's
request their records now important note
two important notes I guess I would say
one scheduled for release Friday to the
committee
so there's two things there one
scheduled for release Friday it's only
Wednesday between now and then Donald
Trump may try more funny business and uh
he his lawyer is saying that they're
going to make another appeal so will the
documents actually be released to the
house committee Friday we don't yet
really know the second part is released
to the committee and I'm continuing to
get emails from folks understandably
excited about these documents saying
when are we going to see them we may
never see them because again it is
released to the committee released to
the committee and um documents sometimes
leak and sometimes are deliberately
leaked it's completely conceivable that
by next Monday we will have a leaked
Call Log of the people Trump spoke to or
a visitor log of the people Trump met
with in the days leading up to the
January 6 riots at the same time that's
not actually what is that issue here
this is about releasing these documents
to the committee not to the public last
thing
this will probably not come as a
surprise to you
but
um well so
this part may be a surprise to you the
judge here judge Tanya chutkin is
Jamaican by origin that you may not have
known
the part that probably wouldn't surprise
you is
the things that are being said by
trumpists
about Judge chutkin
on the basis that she's Jamaican okay if
you go and look at the typical trumpist
enclaves of the internet and this
includes you know pick your pick your
enclave Facebook comments of course
YouTube comments certain subreddits on
Reddit
Twitter
parlor getter I don't even know if
getter is still around
um
there are many trumpists focused
unjudged chutkins Jamaican origin
as a flash point of anger and something
to blame for her decision here
um of course absent any evidence of that
and some may even call that xenophobic
or racist some may you know that's
something I'm reading
um we're going to follow what the
substance of the Trump appeal is and
we'll know Friday or certainly by Monday
whether the committee investigating the
riots has gotten this information all
right next good Trump story
a Donald Trump has released a bizarre
incredibly hyperbolic attack on Senate
now minority leader Mitch McConnell and
this is delightful this is just
delightful so remember that on Monday I
told you about the growing and Brewing
Civil War happening within the
Republican party what were the two sides
of the Civil War I explained on Monday
well one side is trumpist Republicans
all of whom voted against the bipartisan
infrastructure bill passed by the house
on Friday Trump is Republicans who said
we don't want this we're not helping Joe
Biden we're not doing any of it on the
other side of the Republican civil Civil
War were the 13 Republicans who crossed
party lines in the house and did vote
for the tiny comparatively tiny
infrastructure bill
um uh passed by the house on Friday 13
Republicans crossed party lines the
trumpist Republicans went nuts demanding
the removal and promising to primary and
ruin the careers of those 13 Republicans
who said this is a bill that I'm going
to vote for and I said at the time let
him fight encourage them to fight this
is what the left needs because quite
frankly things aren't looking
particularly good for the left right now
in the aftermath of last Tuesday's
elections looking at 2022 the left needs
something Democrats need something
Democrats in the left they overlap a
little but they are two different things
but it's not looking good for either
right now so this is good well we have
another could we call it a rejoinder in
the Republican Civil War Donald Trump
has released a statement trashing Mitch
McConnell for not passing infrastructure
while he was President remember much of
why Trump is opposed to Republicans
helping pass infrastructure now is
regardless of whether it would be good
for the country and Trump said while he
was President it would be good for the
country Trump doesn't want this to be a
victory for Biden because Trump wasn't
able to get it done and so Trump doesn't
want any Republicans to help Joe Biden
because by helping Biden it makes
Trump's lack of passing infrastructure
while he was president look worse
is that true yeah maybe to some degree
maybe to some degree but as Business
Insider points out it was Trump who
walked away from a two trillion dollar
deal back in 2019. take a look at the
statement from Donald Trump released
yesterday through his save America pack
Donald Trump said why is it that old
crow Mitch McConnell voted for a
terrible Democrat socialist
infrastructure plan now by the way
if Joe Biden's 1.2 trillion dollar plan
is socialist how is the two trillion
dollar deal that Trump seemed to want
but ultimately walked away from how is
that not doubly socialist because it's
BS that's that's why
um Trump going on to say
and induced others in his party to do
likewise when he was incapable of
getting a great infrastructure plan
wanting to be put forward by me and the
Republican Party
he continuously said he couldn't get it
passed just like I had to go around him
to get the very popular southern border
wall built which caused Great delay but
could now be completed in one month by
Biden I think there's three lies in that
sentence all of the infrastructure money
two trillion dollars would have gone
into real infrastructure roads Bridges
tunnels airports Etc also why did Mitch
give the Democrats a two-month Hiatus
just long enough for them to figure it
all out when they were completely ready
to fold this is an unhinged man
um it was TR again it was Trump who
walked away from that two trillion
dollar deal he says it was McConnell
Business Insider also writes about this
um in May 2019 Democratic leaders in the
Trump administration had a productive
round of negotiations around a floated
two trillion dollar infrastructure
package but the deal crumbled over the
democratic-controlled house
investigations into Trump after the
release of then special counsel Robert
Mueller's report during a second meeting
with house Speaker Nancy Pelosi and then
Senate minority leader Chuck Schumer
Trump walked out within three minutes of
negotiations
instead of walking in Happily to a
meeting I walk in to look at people that
just said I was doing a cover-up I don't
do cover-ups Trump said at a press
conference
um
yeah so remember it was Trump that
walked away now Trump says he was
justified in walking away but that he it
was still Donald Trump who walked away
from that negotiation so why is this
good well it's good because things are
looking really bad for Democrats right
now things just aren't looking good
you've got a contingent of the left that
might describe itself as the progressive
left although I am on the Progressive
left then I think that we should
actually be working with Centrist
Democrats to extract any victories that
we can but you've got a portion of the
progressive left that still has a sort
of burn it down accelerationist
mentality
that is going to hurt Democrats in their
possibility of getting anything done
Democrats are terrible at campaigning
and the McAuliffe campaign in Virginia
just a disaster it's looking really bad
for 2022 is the point and right now I
think if we had a Trump versus Biden
election held today I think Trump wins
easily
um so the biggest gift that Republicans
can really give Democrats right now is
to fight amongst themselves it's a
really sad commentary on the state of
the democratic party I'm not denying
that it is it is wild that the best
thing Democrats have going for them
right now is that Democrats that
Republicans rather are fighting with
themselves Trump Republicans fighting
with the Republicans that voted for
infrastructure Trump Republicans
fighting with Mitch McConnell because of
uh his actions in the Senate it's sadly
and this is I mean listen
you know I'm not I'm not a Democrat as
many of you know I don't care about the
Democratic party this is a really
embarrassing moment for the Democratic
party given that the most optimistic
thing anybody can point to is
Republicans seem to be damaging
themselves
it says very little about
democratability to get anything actually
done
um but it's a good thing that this is
happening for the country in the sense
that a distracted Republican party a
divided Republican party is a Republican
party that will struggle to get anything
done and may also even struggle to
obstruct the things that Democrats want
to get done we'll see we'll see but
encourage the Civil War and it doesn't
seem to be stopping anytime soon
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
everybody I have a grift alert for you
today
um this is I'm going to give you the
facts that we know but I'm going to tell
you ahead of time I've been looking at
this very strongly for the last 24 to 48
hours my griftometer is going crazy
right you know how like with a geiger
counter when you get close to radiation
it's like it's going crazy the
equivalent of with griftiness grifting
is going off in my head as if I were
next to the equivalent of a uh of a of
uh exposed uranium with a geiger counter
there is a new University being launched
with the help of former New York Times
Reporter Barry Weiss and others called
the University of Austin
um
I'll describe it to you as it's being
reported okay The Daily Beast palantir
founder is backing Bari Weiss no degree
University Weiss is helping launch the
University of Austin it is not yet
accredited and does not offer degrees
okay so right away you have to remember
part of why you go to university is to
learn and part of why you go is because
there is this game it's admittedly it is
a game it's a system in which you need
this degree in order to get certain jobs
and so maybe you would learn at this no
degree no accreditation University but
it would not exactly help you get a job
the former New York Times opinion
columnist Bari Weiss known for her
diatribes against cancer culture
announced Monday she's helping launch a
new University and it's university is in
quotes that will be quote dedicated to
The Fearless Pursuit Of Truth
the somewhat vague mission statement
suggests the institution called the
University of Austin or uatx will be a
home for those who have been shunned
from quote illiberal college campuses
griped uatx's inaugural president Pano
canelos four out of five American PhD
students are willing to discriminate
against right-wing Scholars
the announcement of this was posted to
Bari Weiss's sub-stack newsletter which
you can sign up and pay for if you want
buried in the school's FAQ it does not
actually offer degrees nor is it yet
accredited
also noted in the FAQ the school is
fiscally sponsored by a little-known
non-profit called Cicero research
according to public filing Cicero is
affiliated with Joe Lonsdale co-founder
of the polarizing data mining company
palantir as of 2020 the non-profit
listed no assets Lonsdale is also a
member of the uatx board of advisors a
spokesperson for the school said we're
very proud to have Lonsdale on our board
and as a financial supporter
while less known than another palantir
co-founder the Trump supporting
billionaire Peter Thiel Lonsdale has
courted controversy he assailed Pete
boot Edge Edge for taking paternity
leave
uh any man in an important position who
takes six months of leave for a newborn
is a loser
in the old days men had babies and
worked harder to provide for their
future that's the correct masculine
response
the University of Austin will launch
this summer offering forbidden courses
with provocative questions that often
lead to censorship
oh my God
um my griftometer is going crazy guys
it's going crazy a group of public
figures many of whom are vocal critics
of higher ed or launching in University
reports Bloomberg
the goal is to address a gaping Chasm or
Chasm between the promise and reality of
higher education
the board of advisors includes Lonsdale
I've already mentioned that former
Harvard University president Larry
Summers former ACLU president Nadine
strassen David Mamet Neil Ferguson who's
been a guest on this show I should
mention
um Glenn Beck is really really excited
about this he read like a very strange
scripted thing on his show check this
out we are challenging a jealous
Orthodoxy and expect to be scorned
mocked and viciously attacked but with a
healthy amount of Courage determination
and yes money it can be done right and
when we succeed and look back on this
time we will see that it is a small
price to pay for all that we have gained
from the choice to be bold today right
holy cow
you know we have been saying for a while
that the university system will collapse
on its own weight and that education is
going to have to change but it wasn't
going to do it before America collapsed
on her own weight without somebody
giving I mean the the histrionics and um
uh hyperbole here is just something else
some sort of
leadership
and and another option I mean really
you're down to Hillsdale
as the only University you could go to
this University
uh led by these people
is remarkable absolutely remarkable so
listen
my griftometer is going off the charts
it really is I do want to say there are
people involved with this project that I
don't think are bad people I mean for
example on the website one of the
founding faculty fellows is Peter
bagosian who's been on the show a number
of times
uh he I think respects me as a leftist
who is willing to talk to people of
different views and you know whatever
um I I think Peter burgosian's a good
guy and his intentions have always
seemed on the up and up to me although
sometimes I just don't disagree with his
conclusions about the degree to which
that this higher ed stuff is actually
the problem that he claims it to be I
have no problem with Peter bogosian in
principle and he's involved uh Tyler
Cowan is an economist we've had on the
show I he's involved He's listed on the
website I think a lot of his economic
instincts are excellent and I know that
he kind of I've seen some
shaky cultural stuff from Tyler Cowan
but for the most part I like Tyler Cowan
and I think his economic thinking is
interesting Jonathan height who's been a
guest on this program and I think has
great insights into a number of
different things Arthur Brooks is
involved Arthur Brooks a conservative
but the type of conservative that I
really enjoy speaking with who's been a
guest on this program he's involved I
had a very good conversation with Neil
Ferguson okay fine why does it feel like
a grift
um the drama around
the what I believe is a false belief
that Academia at this point is just
worthless liberal trash and that there
needs to be something like this which
again not accredited for now if that
changes we'll let you know doesn't even
offer degrees this just seems like
something you can pay for to get classes
that might not be that different from
the sub stacks of these people that you
can sign up for and so for now calling
this a university and saying it's in any
way an alternative to actual
universities seems deceptive and like a
complete and total grift that's my view
as of today bearing in mind that there
are people involved with whom I don't
have a problem all right and if they
want to come and talk to me about it
um I'm glad to have them on that's no
problem at all okay this is just kind of
a funny kind of like closing the loop on
a story many of you who have watched my
live streams where we cover White House
Press briefings have seen this reporter
in the room from Newsmax her name is
Emerald Robinson and she is
[Music]
um
and one of the most shocking right-wing
ideologues I've ever come across She was
recently banned from Twitter for posting
wild anti-vaxx nonsense
um including about some kind of element
called luciferase or luciferase you know
Lucifer the devil that she claims is an
ingredient in vaccines
she had a temporary ban on Twitter
was let off the ban and then within
hours she is now permanently banned The
Daily Beast so first of all if you pull
up her account it says account suspended
Twitter suspends accounts which violate
the Twitter rules news max star returns
to Twitter and is permanently banned
banned hours later for vax Insanity
after serving a seven-day suspension for
absurdly claiming vaccines contain a
satan-linked Tracker Emerald Robinson
doubled down on those claims and was
booted from Twitter now again I don't
like to joke about mental illness I'm
not joking about this
but the views about a Satan related
element of vaccines or whatever
these are the types of things where if
your family member was insisting on this
you might say it might be good to see a
psychiatrist it might be good to be
evaluated for possible delusions
psychosis paranoid schizophrenia it's
not a joke
Newsmax White House correspondent
Emerald Robinson has been permanently
suspended from Twitter for repeatedly
violating the social platform's rules
against spreading covet misinformation
Twitter initially gave Robinson who has
relentlessly pushed anti-vaxx falsehoods
for a year a temporary timeout after she
posted an insanely absurd claim that the
coveted vaccines contain a glowing
tracking device linked to the devil she
declared on Twitter quote dear
Christians the vaccines contain a
bioluminescent marker called luciferase
so that you can be tracked read the
latest book of the New Testament to see
how this ends she was banned for a week
um
while some vaccine research has used the
enzyme luciferase which has
bioluminescent features it is not an
ingredient of any coveted vaccines on
the market further it doesn't have any
satanic associations despite deriving
its name from the Latin word Lucifer
which means light bearing
besides receiving the reprimand from
Twitter Robinson was also benched by
Newsmax over her false claims about
vaccines prior to taking Robinson off
the air Newsmax publicly rebuked its
controversial star okay so cut to
yesterday after serving her week-long
Twitter lockout the conservative
Firebrand returned to the social media
site with a fury on Tuesday morning
proclaiming she was back on Twitter at
least seemingly showing thread shade at
Newsmax for sidelining her Robinson then
promoted her account on substack a
subscription newsletter service join me
at sub stack before I'm banned again
and then she tweeted one more thing the
new covet antibody test is called Satan
and it uses luciferase no I'm not
kidding it's not an accident that
they've given this name to this test
it's a warning Twitter decided to shut
her account down for good
um permanently suspended for repeated
violations of covid misinformation
policy unclear whether she will be back
on the air at uh Fox News Fox News at
Newsmax again
um
this to me
seems like someone who is really sick
really sick it seems almost Beyond
herself it's not even she's doing this
as a calculated thing because it'll reap
some kind of financial or other reward
on the end she's potentially just going
to lose her job and she's suspended from
Twitter and it's hard to imagine too
many people would sign up for her sub
stack maybe it's viable maybe it's not
she just seems sick and unfortunately
you know with a lot of these things as
I've said before there are unbalanced
people
and it's just a matter of what do you
come across that you get fixated with
just as easily as she's obsessed with
antibody vaccine Satan you know this
this type of stuff right now and it
seems to be an outlet for a completely
delusional person disconnected from
reality it could just as easily be
something else it could be flat Earth
could be JFK could be water turning
frogs gay you know whatever right it
just it's it's someone who is
susceptible to this because of something
that they have going on and it's not a
joke to say in other contexts
if you were a parent
and your 16 year old kid
started saying in serious ways that they
have these beliefs you might say let's
make an appointment with a psychiatrist
it's not a joke I'm not trivializing
mental illness when I say it this is
someone who looks very very sick but for
the good of the broader Community it's
the right decision to ban her from
Twitter that's uh for sure we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
David P you can call anytime you want
here's a caller this is sad this actual
again this we're not joking here this
caller feels that his mom
is now officially off the deep end based
on the bumper stickers she now has put
on her vehicle
oh David it finally happens yep my mom
is pretty anti-budden I send a picture
today of her College shows a new bumper
sticker
says proud member of the
fjb LGB community right
now that's not LGBT remember
um fjb is f Joe Biden and LGB is let's
go Brandon which is
supposed to allude to F Joe Biden it's
the same thing
um I the number of emails and voicemails
I get from people who sound almost
despondent like that guy because a
parent or even sometimes a significant
other
has gone completely off the deep end
into these non-thinking movements it's
actually sad it's genuinely sad how many
people call and say I just don't know
what to do anymore do I cut this person
off uh there are sometimes parents will
call and say my parents are off the deep
end and I'm wondering if I need to cut
them off from my kids in other words the
grandkids of the parents uh because I
don't I don't want to I don't want them
hearing this stuff I don't want them
around really really difficult and with
Thanksgiving coming up now just a couple
weeks away
I anticipate I'm gonna keep getting the
calls with concerns about Thanksgiving
Gatherings as we do every year but it
seems particularly bad this year because
not only is it do I want my kids around
the anti-vaccine
uh in some cases statements from parents
cousin uncle whoever do I want my kids
around unvaccinated people do I want to
be around unvaccinated people at
Thanksgiving so it's gonna it's gonna be
an interesting one to put it lightly we
have a fantastic bonus show planned for
you today we will talk about Singapore
is now saying if you are unvaccinated by
choice not because of a medical reason
if you're unvaccinated by choice you're
not going to get uh free health care
anymore if you have covid and you're
unvaccinated by choice we're not
covering your your care
um GE conglomerate GE is splitting into
three companies why and what are they we
will tell you and Congress is now
getting I guess you could say more
aggressive with car makers and saying
you have to figure out a way to stop
drunk driving we have to fix this at the
Car Technology level is it the right
approach and what tools do car makers
have that they might use to stop drunk
driving all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and we will see you then
or tomorrow if you're not a member
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors all form is the
easiest way to customize your own
premium sofa I have two all-form sofas
at home love them both go customize your
sofa shipping is fast and free and
you'll get 20 off when you go to
allforum.com Pacman